Hey,
what's going on is bill burns time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 1st,
2018 what's going on?
How are you?
What are you doing?
Are you going to go sober?
October?
C'Mon man,
it rhymes.
Everybody's doing it.
I think Rogan and those guys are doing it again.
Um,
I would,
I would do it.
Um,
but uh,
I'm doing Boston this weekend and there's no fucking way.
Okay.
This just certain cities you can't stay sober and all right.
And that's one of them.
So,
um,
how about take it easy?
October settled down there fucking October.
Um,
anyways,
I just got back from Denver.
I'll tell you what a weekend I had.
Um,
by the way,
the fucking cab driver almost killed me coming home for the fucking airport.
She was a sweetheart,
right?
Talking about kids,
she's a grandmother and all that.
Oh Wow.
It's got to be amazing and blah,
blah.
She goes to make a left onto my street and ran.
She turns her left hand,
turns at signal on for whatever reason,
she just starts drifting and she's coasting up to what she's going to stop,
you know,
to make a left.
She starts drifting like over,
like the white dotted line there into the right lane.
So now people can't go in the left lane and she's also in the right lane.
And I'm literally like moving away from the door like what the fuck?
And people are slowing down beeping at her.
So she just cuts the wheel hard.
Rather than pulling up a little bit and getting in the lane,
she cut the wheel,
hearts are fucking ass.
Her right ass cheek of her Prius was sitting in that fucking lane.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
we're going to get killed.
So there's all these cars come in and people are beeping at her and I could feel
her getting stressed.
So I just calmly just said,
uh,
yeah.
You know,
there's a lot of traffic this time of day,
you know,
there's always a lot of traffic.
You know,
what are you going to,
I just nice and fucking chill.
Like,
I'm not getting impatient,
right.
But she's still gotten patient and she saw a gap and she shoots through it and I
see this fucking guy on a motorcycle that's a little ahead of the pack of the
cars and you know,
it's two lanes on the other side of the road.
He's in the right lane and um,
she pulls out and I just go,
guy in the motorcycle got a motorcycle.
I thought the guy was going to fucking t bone,
right.
The bright into me and she gets across the street and she laughs at me.
She goes,
I saw him,
I saw him.
It's like you fucking saw him and you still went.
I'm telling you that she needed glasses because every time she would pull up to
a red light,
she would stop like 20 car lengths behind and then slowly,
slowly like creep up.
So I don't know what her fucking deal.
She's like,
I saw him.
They saw him.
Yeah,
I saw him too.
You just didn't see the fucking look on his face.
Look like Eli Eli Manning two weeks ago,
you know when his face is all mushed up.
He had that,
you know,
like you saw that chicken the ring.
Um,
yeah,
that's one of those things where I was just like,
I know what that feels like.
Okay.
She scared the fucking shit out of that guy
cause he had like a bunch of cars behind him too and he had fucking slam on that
slam.
But he had to like,
there was,
it was definitely
okay.
All right.
Let's be honest,
you almost die.
Every time we get on a motorcycle is pretty much what happens.
So I would say on a,
on a scale of one to 10,
that was,
it was a good six.
It was a six,
but as six on a motorcycle is a fucking,
you know,
that's like a nine in a car.
It's probably even worse.
It's even worse because it's like,
you know,
you've got an air bags and shit.
It's,
yeah.
Um,
anyways,
I saw him,
I saw him
fucking laughing at me.
Like I'm a fucking little girl in the back seat.
I'm like,
oh,
fake.
You know,
I dunno where you're from with that Transylvanian fucking accent,
but uh,
I don't know how you do it over there.
We got back waves over here.
Bay.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
what was it?
Friday night,
I actually did a sold out show at the fabulous forum in Los Angeles.
The same place.
Okay.
Where,
you know Larry Bird Magic Johnson had their great battles.
What Kevin Mchale fucking clothes line fucking Nah,
Kurt Rambis all of that shit.
I saw the Great Mario Lemieux play there.
I saw Wayne Gretzky play there.
Um,
I remember seeing the 1999 Lakers there with like fucking shack and Colby with
del Harris coaching and I believe Dennis Rodman was on that team.
MMM.
And then I knew,
I saw the foo fighters,
I saw the queens of the stone age.
I,
uh,
saw a bunch of shows there and then all of a sudden I'm fucking that man.
It was unbelievable.
So I want to thank everybody who came out to the show.
MMM.
Not gonna lie.
It might've been the best show of my career.
I thank fucking Christ because I had a bunch of friends there and that was not
the one we wanted to walk off stage.
Like,
ah,
I hit the warning track and every not,
that was good.
It was an impressive poppop to make it out to end the inning bill.
Um,
but we went down there,
um,
okay.
During the day,
me and dean and all these guys went down there and,
uh,
you know,
did the deal,
I sat at the drums and all that.
We played a dean was posting clips and Shit.
Dean's never sung any better and it was just,
it was fucking,
it was awesome.
But I almost fucked up because we played from two 30 to like six o'clock,
two 30 to fucking six o'clock.
And like I was gassed around five and a then another buddy of ours showed up
right at five.
So we played for like another hour.
And the forum people were so cool because they wanted us done by like five 30
and we just kept pushing it a little bit and I got off the stage and I was
fucking wiped out.
Um,
and I was like,
oh no,
did I just fucking use up all my energy for the show?
But fortunately,
uh,
you know,
the butterflies get going and everything and uh,
it was so fucking cool.
They got a,
they got you,
they give you this little gift bag.
I'll tell you this food when you guys,
you guys work there eventually,
right when you guys listened to,
when you fucking sell it out.
Um,
they got it says,
uh,
what'd it say?
The forum backstage is just really super fucking high quality,
like tote bag.
It's something that I would never take,
but it had,
it had like,
it was embroidered and it had like the forum logo on it.
Um,
then inside it had a bunch of t shirts and,
and as a fucking hoodies and stuff that all said that a backstage thing on it.
So it's kind of a fucking obnoxious thing to where if you have it,
I guess you'd have to know,
you'd be like,
oh,
that guy must have fucking performed at the forum.
But it was,
it was fucking,
it was so cool.
So anyway,
so I'm waiting to go up and I got to a dean and fucking Joe Barton,
nick destroyed and they went up there like they were going up at like the
fucking,
the store,
the laugh factory,
not announcing their Dean's always just fucking got his arms up,
like this is going to be fucking awesome.
So he went up there,
crushed it,
comes off stage,
he's got like goosebumps and Shit fucking,
you know,
Christmas morning grin on his face and then Barton it goes up there just fucking
levels the place.
And uh,
I dunno,
I kind of fed off that.
I'm like,
well,
these guys aren't even fucking nervous.
So I went out there and the sound is incredible in that place because,
um,
now it's,
it's strictly a music venue.
So they fixed all the sound and you know,
shit wasn't bouncing around all over the place and,
uh,
the crowd,
you know,
you could bring him up,
he could bring him down to a whisper and then get them going again.
And I did like 90 minutes,
literally didn't want to get up to stage,
but I was so fucking
focused on having a good show because,
uh,
you mean every time I land at lax,
I look at that building and also the new football stadium,
they make it.
But I always look at the La Forum and I always just think of the showtime Lakers
and the Boston Celtics and uh,
and the Pistons when they played them in the fine,
just think of all of that like legendary eighties NBA hoop.
And,
uh,
if I fucking had a bad set there,
every time I landed,
I'd have to be like,
oh,
and I bombed there.
So,
um,
I was on stage about 40 minutes before I finally stopped and took in the fact
that I was there.
It was so like,
you know,
focused on just having a good show and I,
I fucking,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I got all of that one.
I walked out of there.
No fucking regrets.
So,
um,
I really want to thank everybody.
I know I've already said that,
but I really want to thank everybody that showed up.
That was like the fucking night of my life.
And um,
you know,
I had this great after party.
There was all these friends,
people from emphasis of family,
um,
comedians and the people I took acting class with,
my,
my wife went out of the way in w you know,
invited all these friends and families and um,
it was fucking killer,
right?
And,
but typical meat,
I'm sitting there,
I'm having a good time and all that shit.
And then it's just like,
I have like a 9:44 AM flight the next day to go to fucking Denver,
right.
To work with fucking the pride at Trenton,
New Jersey,
Paul Versey.
Right.
So I kind of learned something,
right?
Cause I went the next day I went to Denver and it was this beautiful opera
house,
right?
Just fucking beautiful.
But it had these really high,
high,
high ceilings in the balconies were way in the back.
And I think that's so those people sing opera that were ridiculous so they can
just blast it out.
And it just fills up the whole arena.
Like I,
that's something I,
I,
you know,
when I was in Italy,
I wanted to go to one of those and just see what the big deal was.
You know,
see if it made me cry.
I had to bring a handkerchief.
That's the funniest shit ever.
Those are the old Italian guys go in there fucking crying.
So it was designed for that.
Then I came in there with my fucking Dick and shit show and,
uh,
I couldn't really hear myself from the first show and I'm kind of shouting and I
had gone on Twitter and I was reading all these,
all this fucking,
you know,
the hysteria that's on Twitter right now with this,
this,
uh,
I,
and a Ford thing going on.
And it's,
it's just everybody is just yelling at each other and just,
everybody's making these fucking,
I'm doing it right now saying everybody,
but there's a lot of people are just making these fucking huge,
huge,
huge statements on both sides.
All of them just inflammatory for the most part.
And,
um,
I was the,
I said this,
it's just fucking insane.
So many people who are making the case about themselves under the guise of
supporting the defendant,
you know,
and then there was all these other fucking idiots on the other side,
like a Yo,
fuck,
that bitch is dead meat meatheads shit.
And um,
I mean I'm a comedian,
I got to know what's going on.
So I was just sort of reading that and it just sort of affected my attitude when
I went on stage.
I think I just came out too fucking hard and sounded too angry and I had to kind
of adjust on the,
uh,
the second show and then I couldn't,
I couldn't really hear myself.
Um,
but we got it fixed for the next show and then Sunday night it was great.
But uh,
yeah,
I kind of learned something where it's like when you do a show as big as that,
you just,
you don't want to do it again for like five days,
you know,
and then go to a really fucking small place kind of bomb a little bit and just
sort of shake off the memory of what you just did.
And then you can just go back to being normal again.
Because I'm,
I was like,
I was all over the map,
the first show.
Like I was still thinking about the forum the night before going,
oh wait,
I did the joke this cause it was,
you know,
it was fucking,
it was him.
It was incredible experience.
Um,
the only I can equate it to is when I drank again is in Ireland.
And I remember drinking it.
Go on,
this fucking doesn't taste any different than America.
And then I came back to America and I fucking drank a Guinness and I almost spit
it out.
So then when I had to do was I had to go fucking drink like Busch light,
you know,
and work my way back up to American Guinness word tasted good again.
You know what I mean?
I think when you have like a big fucking night,
it's probably not a good idea to have a 9:44 AM flight the next fucking day and
then have to go,
you know?
Okay.
I Dunno.
I,
I was like,
it was kind of beating myself up,
going to help them,
but at the end of the end of the show that they fucking stood up and they had a
good time and I was like,
oh,
that was one of those ones.
Like I couldn't hear the fucking laughter.
So,
um,
I want to thank everybody in Denver came out just fucking crazy,
insane,
great crowds tonight.
This is just me kissing everybody's fucking ass.
Thank you for,
you know,
Denver is a place that I've always loved going,
but I didn't really get to get out too much,
you know,
cause I felt like I was going to get sick and for once in my fucking life,
um,
I actually was like,
you know what,
I'm just going to stay in the fucking hotel room and just rest up.
Uh,
which is basically what I did.
So I didn't even get,
I,
you know,
I always walk around,
I always go out,
they have like these train tracks,
things,
you know,
and there's all these like fucking white kids you see out there.
It's like a,
is that kid homeless or as he's playing hacky sack with a hacky sack with the
fuck,
like you know,
a lot of that fucking,
uh,
we'd vibe,
you know,
when they've got all these great fucking food and I missed all of it,
but I did go to Churchill's last night and had a nice fucking cigar.
So,
um,
anyways,
sorry man.
I know this is like a big fucking hallmark Goddamn podcasts,
but whatever.
It's not every day you do the form.
I don't know if I'll ever fucking get to do that again.
Hopefully I will.
If I don't,
I did it.
I could have done it any fucking better.
Do they painted my name on the fucking wall?
You know,
you look around,
it's just like ACDC,
James Brown,
all of this fucking shit.
And there's my stupid name.
I mean,
I'm sure they're going to park the forklift in front of it,
but a whatever for one night for one night.
Um,
anyways,
um,
let's talk formula one racing.
I keep forgetting because my fucking got fucked up.
I saw,
I watched the highlights.
Lewis Hamilton won over there.
I believe it was in Russia.
Right.
And,
uh,
it's a question I have for all you fucking race fans out there.
Can somebody explain to me like botox is winning the fucking race,
you know,
and then like,
cause Lewis Hamilton,
you know,
wants to fuck,
he's in second and in federal is in third and Hamilton has a lead.
But if he,
if he,
if he gets in first then it'll have a 50 point fucking lead and Rosberg is his
teammates.
So the team asks Rosberg to get out of the way so Lewis will can pass him.
And then his job is just basically then to be a con to v basically race against
Sebastian Vettel to keep the Ferrari team destiny.
I mean he basically,
you know,
for all extensive purposes,
he pretty much wrapped up the fucking thing unless he crashes or something.
Federal comes in first,
but even then he would only cut his league and half and he's like,
Hamilton always makes the fucking podium.
So,
um,
I get the whole team mate thing,
but I remember when fucking him and Nico Rosberg we're going at it two years ago
and the team asked Louis to fucking move to the side.
He's like,
Nah,
I'm good,
I'm good.
And I'm sitting there like going,
all right,
is that because the way he's made up,
he's a champion.
That's what makes him a champion.
Should botox spend like,
Nah,
I'm fucking good.
I'm good.
Was Louis in a position because he's such a star to say no,
I'm good to the fucking team and botox isn't yet.
But through the guy was like fucking,
I mean these guys,
this is what they do.
They fucking race.
It goes against everything in their fucking nature to do that.
And they had a race.
Louis is just like a,
yeah,
a Terry,
he was,
he was a gentleman out there today,
blah blah.
I wanted somebody be like,
Hey Louis,
if you had done that for him,
I don't think you would have.
Um,
anyways,
Max for staff and got driver of the day.
You had like fucking three penalties.
He started way in the back and just within five laps was up to like fifth or
sixth place.
It was like watching fucking stroke or race.
And when you watch your movies,
like nobody can pass people that,
it doesn't happen like that in a race.
If you started in 19 ticket,
the whole fucking race to get up to the front sky and five laps gave everybody
the old right,
they're friends.
So I got my DVR set for that and I'm backing with the Moto GP and I'm very
excited to uh,
be watching that shit.
I just got all this,
these run,
run a dates right up until,
uh,
the Chicago theater and then old Billy boys year is done.
I fucking year is done.
I got a couple of fucking,
whatever I got to promote.
F is for family season three whenever we get the date.
And we'd be doing that towards the end of the year.
So I will be kind of,
it never ends.
It's basically what I'm saying.
I'll be flying around fucking promoting the show,
but I won't be doing like show.
So my,
my year ends with the Chicago theater right after MSG,
Madison Square Garden.
Um,
then that's it.
Hopefully I'll be watching the patriots and fucking first place and the AFC
east.
Huge,
huge fucking,
when do you realize that we lost just today we would be three games behind the
dolphins,
essentially making planes to try to get the wildcard that look like,
like the Patriots team that I've been spoiled to watch every week.
Um,
we got a short week though,
and I don't think Edelman's back on Thursday,
so we'll see.
We shall see.
And I was so polling for the fucking Cleveland Browns to get two wins in a row
by like the Raiders through.
So it was Kinda cool,
but I just,
I just wanted to see,
you know,
I dunno,
I've already just,
I've already mentally dealt with the fact that Brady's not going to be here in a
couple of years and all these young kids that I see a coming up,
we're going to be the next ones.
And,
uh,
so I don't want to hate on him,
so I'm just fucking rooting for him even though I know we're going to go right
in the fucking shit.
The second Tom,
Tommy fucking leaves the Goddamn facility.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
did I fucking call the NFC south or did I call it fucking told you?
There's no defense in that entire division.
Look what happened when they played the fucking bears.
Who had a defense?
What the fuck was this score?
It was like 48.
That's fucking seven.
Let's see here.
NFL scores.
What do we got here?
Okay,
of course you got every goddamn score except that one.
What do you guys like tonight?
The chiefs of the Broncos,
I would take the Broncos and the points,
cause they'll division rivalry games are always close and everyone's going to be
all about the,
Oh my God,
the,
that Ma my home or whatever the fuck his name is.
This guy's a juggernaut.
He's due to have a bad game,
right?
He's a rookie.
It'll happen bucking it.
I mean a bucket needs the fucking Broncos.
They play the chiefs twice a year,
then they're not afraid.
These fucking assholes.
I would take them in the points.
Okay,
von Miller will be a fucking pain in that guy side.
Uh,
that's what I would do.
But Versie what?
Versus going to go to the game and he's going to Barry,
he's gonna bury the fucking chiefs.
Who knows?
We'll see who's right out.
The score was 48 to 10 pairs.
Um,
and I was also right about the Yankees after we swept them all.
Yeah,
it's fucking over the red.
The Yankees is still a year away.
Red sox are looking like they're going to win the world series.
Now look what happens.
Send Chris Sale,
can't get fucking healthy price.
Can't beat the fucking Yankees.
The Yankees Win for the next fucking six and they're one winner today.
They went today,
they,
I think they play the red sox and then they go,
it's like when you watch Friday the 13th,
they always fucking knocked Jason down and they'd hack on one fucking time and
then he always get back up.
You got to finish him off.
It ain't over until it's over.
So we shall see.
But I'm telling you,
my call is,
I think the Indians and the Astros,
um,
Terry Francona scares the shit out of me.
And when I saw the Astros win the first two games against the red sox and they
had a chance,
they came like they were winning and then we,
I think we rallied and we were ahead and then all of a sudden,
right at the end of the game,
they had a chance of sweeping us.
And when in that last game they were all up on the top step of the Dugout,
the whole fucking dug out.
We're all standing up there like,
let's sweep their fucking acids.
And I think,
I think the,
I think they're feeling a little disrespected out there.
Um,
so we shall see.
Have I said one funny fucking thing,
this entire thing.
I just been like giving out information.
Um,
speaking of which more information,
all things,
comedy,
uh,
atc.com.
Uh,
we are,
we are releasing our first,
um,
stand up special on our website and it's the great tell Ted Alexandro,
who's really a comic's comic.
He just has some,
he's just,
he just has some of the best fucking jokes and he's one of these guys that is
just so overdue and deserving of a special.
So,
um,
you can watch it date.
What is the date?
They fucking putting this thing out.
Hopefully.
I got it.
Okay.
This Thursday,
you can,
what?
You can stream it@atcspecials.com.
Now,
this is huge for,
uh,
for our website here that you guys,
you know,
watch it and get people in here.
We can retweet it and get people to,
to watch the special.
Um,
dad is fucking hilarious.
It's a great special.
Um,
like I said,
Thursday,
ATC specials.com.
Um,
please check that out.
All right,
let me do a little fucking,
uh,
some advertising reads here,
shall we?
Shall We?
All right.
Oh,
look who's here.
Old Zip.
Okay.
Growed up.
Uh,
you know what's not smart?
Not Smart is written in capital letters.
So I yell at whenever it is.
Okay?
You know what's not smart jobs?
Sites said overwhelm you with tons of the wrong resumes,
but you know,
what is smart zip recruiter.com/burr unlike other job sites,
zip.
Yeah.
Uh,
it doesn't wait for candidates to find you.
Zip recruiter finds them.
It's powerful.
Matching technology scans thousands of resumes,
identifies people with the right skills,
education,
and experience for your job and actively invites them to,
to apply.
Oh,
that's cool.
It actually goes out.
Hey,
hey,
by the way,
you're qualified for this.
We'd love to have you.
She's saying you're invited.
So you get qualified candidates fast.
No more sorting through the wrong resumes.
No more waiting for the right candidates to apply.
No more something else.
They didn't write anything else,
but you know,
you always need three,
right?
It's no wonder that zip,
okay.
Yeah.
Is rated number one by employees in the u s this rating comes from hiring sites
on trust pilot with over 1000 reviews.
And right now my listeners can try zip
for free at this,
uh,
exclusive web address.
ziprecruiter.com/burr,
that's ziprecruiter.com/bar a B.
U.
R.
R high zip.
Yeah.
[inaudible] dot com slash bar tip occurred at the smartest way to hire.
All right.
Oh look who's he ate?
My fucking can.
Yay My bookie show.
Watch football is fun,
but it's more entertaining.
When you got a little action on the Games,
guys,
you've heard me talking about this for weeks and some of you are still on the
sidelines with the junk tucked between your thighs,
whether you're an expert or a rookie,
you should be betting at my bookie.
If you're the kind of guy that likes to bed a little and when a lot like playing
the numbers on the bond roulette,
you can create a big parlay.
Pick three teams to win,
and if you hit all three,
you'll turn a hundred dollars into $600 it's not just football.
You can bet all major sports.
You could bet on what time your wife's going to start complaining,
not take MMA this weekend.
Oh my God.
You can bet on this.
CONOR MCGREGOR,
I can't wait for this fight.
Steps into the octagon Saturday for his first UFC UFC fight in two years.
That was two years ago.
Jesus Christ.
Time's flying.
You can bet on things like whether he'll win straight up or weather.
Oh God,
I better say this guy's named Roy Kabib.
Is that what it is?
I will deliver a first round KL I wreck.
I recommend,
hey,
what's the over under that?
He's going to say you're going to do nothing.
I love when he says that you'll do nothin.
I don't know what that is.
A ringtone.
I want that on my phone.
Right next.
My wife yells at me.
I just want to press that.
You'll do a,
I recommend these guys because I really trust them.
Evidently.
Uh,
this is the one bet I know you'll be happy with all season.
My bookie.
Are you doing?
There has been in business for years.
They've got great online reviews and their mobile site is easy to use.
If you're on the sidelines.
Now is the time to get the game.
My bookie,
the hough will still match your first deposit,
dollar for dollar,
but you got to join now because there'll be pulling that offer.
Log onto my bookie,
my buggy.
Are you doing?
Oh,
I'm just listening right now and double your money.
Use Promo Code and you'll get your four.
I guess it's burrow.
I'm guessing.
I have no idea.
And you'll get your first deposit matched 100% that's promo code parentheses,
Promo Code.
What the fuck is my Promo Code?
Am I going to get paid?
Uh,
you play,
you win.
You get paid.
I would just use bur wasn't it bill bets?
I can't remember.
All right.
Oh look who's here.
Dollar Shave Club.
Dope Dude.
You have a fucking shower.
Is Stinky mother fucker or brush your teeth or try to make your hair look
presentable.
Well here's some good news.
Don't what?
Don't cry.
Wait till you fucking hear what it is.
Okay.
Dollar Shave Club has a lot of stuff to help you out.
It's kind of a fucking let.
Here's some good nose exclamation point.
Dollar Shave Club has a lot of stuff to help you out.
Not saying it's not exciting,
but I don't think it's exclamation point.
Exciting Dollar Shave Club.
Yes.
That dollar shave club delivers everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best.
You name it.
Shampoo,
conditioner,
body wash,
toothpaste,
Hair Gel,
condoms.
We don't do that.
Even a wipe that will leave your tush feeling tingly,
clean.
Yes it does.
It's like there has a winter greens or something on it.
Makes your asshole fill alive.
Uh,
you'll be a big fan of their amber in Labrador calming body cleanser after you
try it the first time.
I should walk around with that shit on me just to keep my temper in check.
Good luck finding a product that great at the store.
All of dollar shave club's products are made with top shelf ingredients that
won't break your budget.
You'll feel the difference.
Plus shipping is free with your membership.
And here's a great way to try a bunch of dollar shave club products for just
five bucks.
You can get their daily essential starter kit.
It comes with body cleanser,
one wipe Chari.
They're amazing,
but wipes their world's famous shaved and their best razor.
This six blade executive,
keep the blades coming for a few bucks more a month,
add in some shampoo,
toothpaste or anything else you need for the bathroom.
Check it all out@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/burb alright.
Indochino uh,
talk about how the company is expanding into casual clothing and made to Mather
measured Chinos.
We're Indochina was also expanding into casual clothing.
Yeah,
I'm supposed to talk about that.
Hey everybody,
the companies expanding into casual clothing with may the Mather measure Chinos.
We're Indochina was also expanding into the cat.
Isn't that the same thing the company guys?
I'm too dumb to fucking talk about your stuff for you.
Just tell me what this,
just write it and I'll read it anyways.
You're made to measure Chinos.
We'll quickly come become your goto pant pairing as easily with a suit jacket as
they do with a sweater.
Um,
what are Chinos?
Are those like cool.
Dockers?
Let's look those up for a second.
Let's take a little pause here.
Let's see what we got here.
Chinos pants.
Let's see what they look like.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I,
I uh Oh my God.
Oh,
I see what they are.
they're all snug.
All snugged up on your nuts and your fucking ass.
Making sure everything stays high and tight.
Um,
it's like a facelift for your junk.
anyways.
Then there'll be good anytime a year for any occasion from boredom boardroom
meetings to Sunday brunches.
Oh,
you got to love a pair of pants like that,
right?
Somebody died.
They get married.
I got the pants and don't Chino at at an introductory price of $79.
US.
Fuck Bill.
Come on.
Here's how it works.
Visit a stylist at our showroom and have them take your measurements personally.
They're going to.
We have a stylist for $79 pants or
measure@homeyourselfandshoponlineatindochino.com choose your fabric inside and
out.
Choose your design customization.
Submit your measurements with your choices.
Relaxed while you're suit gets professionally tailored and mailed to you in a
couple of weeks.
This week,
my listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for 359 dollars@indochino.com
when entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for a made to measure premium suit plus
shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code [inaudible] for any premium suit for just $359
in shipping is free.
One more people just hang in there.
I know it's rough.
I know you're having a hard time watching other people go through a hard time.
Um,
I really,
I really wish I could read you cause I started,
I,
I actually,
I'm following a couple of people now.
Um,
I didn't sign up because I know that they would know that I was following them
sarcastically.
But yeah,
we just have an account.
You just have to check in on,
check in on.
I saw one,
I,
I can't,
I can't even,
like this person basically
was a stunning,
beautiful blonde,
white woman and she was talking about how difficult it was to look the way she
does.
She compared yourself to like a mermaid.
Like that's what she looked like.
Then she did all this other stuff,
you know,
so she wouldn't be so pretty and get all this fucking attention.
Um,
and I'm not saying like,
you know,
I'm not talking about creepy guy behavior.
I'm just people looking at it or whatever.
She's fucking stunning.
You know what I mean?
And it's just like,
well look,
if you're never going to wait in a line in life,
I mean there's the,
there's,
there's like a price to pay,
you know?
Does that make any fucking sense?
I mean,
I get this fucking thing where it's just like,
okay,
there's so many fucking problems in the world right now.
It wants to someone like that.
And I'm not talking about me too shit.
I'm just saying this person is just fucking not even talking about like me too
shit.
It's just somehow making all of this me too shit about just as an excuse to talk
about how fucking beautiful she is basically,
and how difficult it is.
You know?
It's like you,
you fucking should travel a little bit.
Get outside this country,
you know,
go find the people that actually are making our clothing and see what their life
is.
And then tell me how fucking difficult your fucking life is.
You know?
And if we're going to focus on anything in this country,
why don't,
well,
how about this next.
Okay.
Other than cleaning up all the fucking pollution.
What about,
you know how you bite into an apple and there's a seed?
If you plant in the ground,
it won't fucking grow anymore because some company made sure it would.
You know
so many noted the fucking goddamn food.
It's unbelievable
that a fucking Pete,
you know,
not a fucking people about stamps.com everybody would.
I walked down the street.
It's a beautiful person not having to stand in line getting free drinks.
It's really hard.
Okay?
Oh yeah.
Well,
why don't you fucking put your arms behind your back,
put on some red bottom shoes and do a face plant into the fucking sidewalk.
Okay.
I'm sure you won't have any more fucking difficulty with everybody's jaw
dropping when,
well,
maybe they'll depend on how bad you fuck yourself up.
stamps.com everybody,
the US Postal Service is an important tool for any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access all the amazing service services of the
post office.
stamps.com never closes.
Hey guys,
this should be a new fucking segment.
Okay.
Oh,
this is step on the toes of humble bragging though.
I don't want to do that.
Especially because the guy that created that unfortunately passed away and I
don't want to be doing somebody else's bit,
Ooh.
Can't even call me out on it.
All right.
But if you guys could just send me like,
I just want to read.
Okay.
The craziest tweet.
The from most self involved,
too angriest,
craziest.
Both liberal and,
and,
and conservative cause everybody's just fucking
like freaking out.
Somebody wrote the me too.
Movement is getting out of hand now.
It only takes 20 accusers to slightly inconvenience a wealthy man,
man with unchecked power.
Uh,
that's what I like.
How everybody like fudges the numbers.
It's like,
no,
that's not what happened.
That's not what they'll,
there's been just one person says something and then somebody loses their
fucking career and then it's investigated and then a month later finds out that
it was bullshit.
And then nobody,
everybody who is trashing the person,
nobody issues of fucking apology to the person.
And then the person who is innocent as to then fucking try to figure out how to,
how to get,
you know,
they have to strategize as an innocent person.
How do get back into the fucking business.
MMM.
You know,
but I don't,
I don't want everything just to be trashing me too.
Like,
cause like,
I'll be honest with you.
Okay.
I usually don't say I vote for,
I like that Ford woman.
I believe her.
I do.
You know,
again,
this was the big thing for me was the fact that she's been telling this story is
told to a therapist,
she's been,
came forward before against this fucking guy.
I mean,
if this is really just take this guy down,
this has gotta be the,
is,
she's like the terminator of like,
you know,
and he's just an m.
I can't understand if he's just guilty or like
he's a guy,
right?
They're going to grab the brass ring and it's going to have his fucking shorts
are getting yanked out.
And I can't tell if he's just fucking wigging out cause I haven't watched any of
it,
but I just read some details.
So my Breely like,
I'm not going to sit down and fucking give myself jury duty.
Why the fuck would I do that?
You know?
Oh fucking,
you know,
I'll watch the highlights.
You know,
I saw,
I saw Matt Damon crushing it doing that.
My favorite thing was it came out and they said,
Mr Cavanaugh,
he just goes,
what?
Yeah.
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
he's just like all over the fucking map.
And uh,
it reminds me of the Kennedy Nixon debate and I know that's really a hacky
fucking thing.
And I'm not saying she's coming off like Kennedy,
I'm just saying he's coming off like Nixon won.
Nixon didn't know how to sit.
He had sweat on his forehead and that it's like he's judged like this guy's not
supposed to be a performer.
So,
um,
okay.
I Dunno.
It's just one of those things.
If the guy's guilty,
I hope they say he's guilty and if he's innocent,
I hope they say he's fucking innocent so he doesn't get screwed over because
that's,
that's what everybody should want here.
You know,
you should just want a guy to go free because you're a guy and you shouldn't
just want a guide to get his life burned down because you know you're a woman.
You should,
you know,
it's kind of,
it's weird.
It's like people are starting to root for this shift the way they root for their
sports team,
where if they have one of their players does a piece of shit move to ask,
it's not that bad.
But then somebody else to od,
this guy's up there.
There are pieces of shit we're not,
you know.
But anyways,
just so there's some sort of fucking humor in it because it really fucked with
my attitude for the first 10 minutes of my set Saturday night.
And that's not fair to the people,
you know,
that pain to see a show.
So someday,
yeah,
like yesterday I just started seeing the humor in it.
I just started reading them to [inaudible] and I,
and I would just,
I would go,
I just go,
Hey Paul,
like dead serious.
And then I would read the tweet like I was saying it.
Oh wait,
doesn't Jimmy Fallon do that?
Do I have one original fucking idea?
Somebody does that.
Oh No,
you had the,
somebody has people read their,
their fucking hate mail.
Um,
all right,
well now you know why my act as the level that it's at,
because I don't have a fucking original idea.
When are they going to decide with this fucking guy,
by the way,
you know?
Then how the fuck are you doing?
Investigation and a God damn week trying to make sure everybody's stories match
up over something from fucking 30 years ago.
Um,
I dunno man.
I think you just go with your gut.
Yeah.
As far as just if you're just sitting at home,
but like the fact that like,
okay,
what's at stake?
That it,
that that's what they're going to base it on.
I think like,
hey,
he fucking seem crazy.
She seemed believable or she seemed coach and uh,
he seems like a passionate family man,
you know,
I guess that now that doesn't happen when you're going,
when you sit on a jury,
they actually fucking,
they have to prove it.
We aren't a of die.
I mean it's fucking nuts.
But then we get into corporations and shit,
which you saw with Tom Brady.
It's just like,
no.
If we say you're suspended,
you're fucking suspended.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Or,
or civil court like that shit.
We're,
Oj gets acquitted.
He,
he's,
he's not guilty in a court of law,
but he's guilty in,
uh,
what about a civil court?
So it's like,
all right,
you're not going to jail,
but we're taking everything you're out.
You know,
which is crazy to me because now you've got a murderer walking around.
Pissed off that you just took his bed.
Either put them in jail and take all his shit all,
let them go back to his house.
But fuck,
if you're going to,
if you take the guy murdered somebody,
don't take all his shit.
Now he's going to the fucking stories mad again.
So it happened the first time he got mad.
Fuck.
All right.
stamps.com everybody,
the u s postal service is an important tool for any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access all the amazing services of the post
office.
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for any letter or any package at your convenience.
24,
seven print postage for any male class right now from your own computer by in
print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class a mail,
using your own computer and printer.
Uh,
they'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the best class of mail based on your
needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter.
And there are no long term commitments.
I use stamps.com because,
uh,
you know,
I'm sending all my posters,
my autographed posters,
which will it be available in all my shows.
I'm a moron if I can figure out how to use the stupid scale and all of that
crap.
So can you,
um,
absolutely no negative references to the post office.
Okay,
I'll tell you those people down the post office.
Uh,
they're the salt of the earth and right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com
servers with this special offer that includes a four week trial plus postage and
a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter
burr.
Um,
ah righty.
All righty.
All right,
let's get into the reeds here for this week.
Uh,
remembering passwords.
All right,
this is something I have a problem with that you know,
something.
I actually had one
of the few patient moments in my life and I tried to,
because I don't know my iCloud password.
So I finally,
just after a year of just keep axing that window 90 times,
every time I turned on my fucking computer,
um,
I finally went on the Internet and just googled how to,
how to reset it,
which I did.
And I was so excited cause the window finally went away and then I shut off my
computer and then,
you know,
we turned it back on and wants you to re,
um,
putting the,
uh,
the fucking password,
which I did and now it's not accepting it and I'm right back to square one.
And remember when the first time I typed it in,
it didn't work and I did it again and it didn't work.
And as,
as I was hitting sand or whatever,
or Login,
the third time I live,
he said,
my brain built,
don't snap.
Just relax.
You'll figure it out.
And then it didn't go in.
I went out.
Right.
What the fuck fuck about him.
It's every time,
every fucking time.
Um,
anyways,
you know,
it's actually helping.
My temper is watching everybody losing their is on the Internet.
I'm just sitting there going like,
wow,
that's what I sound like.
Jesus Christ,
my wife's living with this.
I think I'm going to buy her some shoes,
some matching earplugs.
Uh,
hey bill.
I was just listening to the latest podcast,
checkout Dash Lane for passwords.
It's easy to use and you can sync it across your computer phones,
et Cetera.
It odd,
it auto populates your username and passwords.
Hope it helps.
That is definitely somebody young who write wrote,
wrote that in,
dude,
why would I,
the purpose of the password is that nobody else knows it.
That's the one they lifelock.
Lifelock is the funniest fucking thing in the world to me.
Yeah,
give us all your personal fucking information.
Now.
Not only do I have to trust you,
okay,
you at this company have now created a Fort Knox of,
well,
I guess Fort Knox never gets broken into it.
You've created a basic,
a giant fucking sack of cash in the walls that everybody's now going to try to
get to.
Why fucking waste my time trying to fucking hack and a cow out here,
a hack and account here.
What I can just hack lifelock and get everybody's fucking shit.
Um,
I appreciate you trying to help me out,
but uh,
I'm going to just continue on,
you know,
I don't know if they're going to hack in,
they're going to hack him,
but I could just never fucking remember my fucking passwords and I don't want to
like
have somebody else do it for me.
My brain's already turning to mush enough as it is.
So,
but you know,
people,
if you want to check out dash lane,
d a s h l a n e for passwords,
uh,
you are more than welcome.
You can get out there and try that out for yourselves.
Um,
all right,
number two.
Hi,
I heard you were struggling with managing passwords.
This is another one I've been using a password called Dash.
Is this like a Reed Dash Lane for awhile?
It's really great and creates really good passwords for you for each website and
automatically logs you in there.
It has a plugin for various browsers and also an APP for Mac.
Oh,
s love it.
Take care.
Yeah,
there's certain things I just don't outsource.
That would be one of them is something I have to check though.
Um,
stem cell.
Okay.
Therapy for hair loss.
Cause I got to tell you something.
I got buddies who have done this for their knees and their fucking shoulders.
Okay.
All right.
And you know our hands or something like that and they say they feel like a kid
again.
Now if there is literally,
if this gets to the fucking point,
if this fucking shit works,
I might go over to Eastern Europe.
I swear to God and I'm going to come back with a full head of hair.
How fucking weird would that be?
That would just be fucking bizarre.
Dude.
Look at this shit.
This is why I shaved my head.
Look at this.
Look at the shit show.
I lost so many of these things that they're showing as like solutions to people
still look terrible.
Um,
all right,
let me see here.
Okay.
Stem cell therapy for hair cell for hair loss.
Hang on a second.
Uh,
reviews,
let's see here.
Let's see what they say.
Now you know the people that do it,
they're just flooding it right now.
This is like trying to find out like what's actually healthy.
I try and to learn about uh,
about Oh hymns.
They reais they fucking see they come up.
Stem cell hair loss,
injections,
do they work?
I would almost do this just for the goof.
You know how funny it would be if I just came back with a lion's mane of fucking
red hair?
You know,
each of us deserves a truly personal,
this is a fucking,
this is stupid.
Like this is the thing that you cannot get past.
Like how far,
how many pages do I have to go where I can actually,
where I can actually fucking just find an,
an,
an actual honest review.
All right.
Oh,W magazine case,
thanks to stem cell therapy.
Thinning hair may be a thing of the past.
You know,
like back in the day when you got like a fucking boil on your face,
you just had to have it for the rest of your life.
Then you started again the walking stick and you got fucking osteoporosis and
you had to go live under a bridge.
Now,
not all of that shit's gone.
Right.
And now I think that hair loss might the same way.
All right.
Call me creature.
A habit or just plain boring.
But I've been wearing my hair long by,
who gives a fuck?
What is this?
Yeah,
these are all just businesses.
Can I ask you young people a question?
How do you find the answers on the Internet?
I don't want a answer.
I want,
I want the answer.
A hairy questions.
Stem Cell to cure baldness in 2017.
All right,
this is what I'm going to do
because I think there's a lot of people doing this right now.
I'm going to wait to somebody just fucking,
who looks like me to just walk in one day,
you know,
looking like a fucking,
all of a sudden just looking like a rockstar and when that fucking goes down,
I gotta be like,
how do you lay off?
I never liked all that other shit cause they're like Yank and shit from the back
and sticking it on top.
But then that's just like,
you know,
does it work?
Does it not work?
Um,
okay.
But they just go,
just,
you know,
you just sit down.
Okay.
They go big bank,
big bank,
boom.
On top of your fucking head,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
you're just watching her,
I don't know,
an episode of fucking a swat or something.
Then you just leave.
You come back.
You look like you're in the fucking bgs.
I'll wait a minute.
Most of them were bald,
right?
Oh yeah.
They're all both right.
We're all dead.
One of them has her hair plugs.
All right.
They like the Kennedy's of uh,
false settle.
Right.
There's like a million of them and they all could just fucking get up there.
All right.
Millennial water crisis.
Dear Beantown,
Billy and your recent Coney and interview.
And this past Thursday you talked about not understanding why millennials freak
out over the water bottle flipping thing.
Even with all the great technology we have.
Yes.
Why do you guys freak out?
It's actually not millennials.
It's the,
uh,
the generation after,
which I keep fucking forget I'm 18 years old generation name.
Is it?
What is an Alpha?
What is it?
Generation z?
A you motherfucker.
Generations.
Which generation are you?
I literally looked this up and I already told you guys the fucking answer.
I already forget.
Yeah.
Generation Alpha.
No,
2013 to 2025,
sorry.
No,
1995.
Okay.
Generation Z.
Alright.
That's what they are.
They can't get enough of that fucking water bottle trick.
Yeah.
Why is that?
He says,
or she says,
I thought I explained my persec perspective on it as a millennial and I think
you,
okay,
now you're a millennial,
right?
And I think you'd appreciate the humor in it.
All right.
As long as you're 23 to 38,
you're a millennial,
uh,
you,
you bringing up the great technology we have is part of the joke.
Oh,
it's a joke.
I'm 26.
Bam.
He nailed it.
And for my entire life,
advertising,
sporting events,
technology,
everything been getting increasingly sold to us as the next big thing or the
best thing ever.
Or a once in a lifetime experience.
Um,
it's all just the same shit rehashed,
over and over with brighter colors in bigger letters.
This year's iPhone is barely better than the last,
but fuck it.
They'll charge a grand more and people will believe it's better.
I like this person fucking critical thinking.
It's a fucking lost start here.
Uh,
as I'm dropping f bombs all over the place,
so freaking out over a water bottle.
Being flipped is funny.
It's the most simple thing.
There's no fanfare,
no tickets being sold,
nothing to advertise.
It's just some someone flipping a water bottle.
So let's freak the fuck out if it lands upright.
That'll be funny.
That's how I see it.
At least.
That was really informing.
Thank you.
Love the podcast.
Thanks for the hours of free and have tape.
Tainment they mean a lot to me.
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right,
thank you.
Well there we go.
I finally got an answer on the Internet.
Um,
okay.
Helicopter scene are got the answer.
I like to think helicopter scene from the Terminator two.
Hey.
Oh Billy 50 year old.
I'm a big fan of the podcast.
F is for family and I especially liked that you're a fan of moto GP.
I,
if I can't get enough of it,
even though I missed the last couple of fucking racist because there's a long
story.
We had issues with their TVs also.
Thanks for introducing me to tales from the tour bus with Mike Judge.
Oh my God,
you got to watch that show.
It's fucking incredible.
I'm not really looking for any advice this time.
Just saw this short video with director's commentary link below about the
skilled helicopter pilot in Terminator two had thought you might like it.
Anyways,
thanks and have a great weekend.
Yeah,
well we'll,
I'll definitely post the link for that.
[inaudible] it said scene in terminator two were the skinny guy,
the next level terminator guy.
Um,
he's in a building and then there's like a helicopter hovering next to it.
He basically turns to like sort of this,
uh,
sort of like a plasma TV sort of type of liquid.
And he just sort of pushes his face into the fucking helicopter.
And then he's sitting next to the guy and he tells the guy to jump out and then
he starts chasing him down the street.
And,
um,
I think it was,
was it James Cameron and did that movie?
Um,
he was talking about being in the helicopter and how they went from like a
thousand feet down to four feet off the fucking ground and like two seconds.
And having that feeling of weightlessness,
um,
I was literally like,
stunt flying in helicopters scares the fucking shit.
I,
my palms get sweaty when I watch it.
I don't know why,
because with like,
I just did something about the main rotor.
I just feel like you're going to hit something with that and you,
and then you're going to be fucked.
But if someone does it in a plane,
it doesn't freak me out as much.
Like the plain seems like it's more designed to do that,
you know,
even though if he clips something with you when you fucked,
but there's just something about it.
Here's a question for you guys in aviation,
right?
I'm just a fucking weekend warrior,
Who got zero hours this past month?
I would get so busy.
Um,
I was watching that Tom Cruise movie that was a great movie where he played this
uh,
this drug smuggler.
It's a long story but they,
the three of them are flying in planes and the DEA was chasing the da had like a
fucking jet and they just had like a twin engine so they were able to fly much
slower.
And so the,
the,
the DEA kept catching up and then would pass them and then loop around,
catch up to them and then pass them.
Cause you know,
he couldn't fly slower.
You fall out of the fucking sky.
So eventually the DEA runs out of gas.
It was going to run out of fuel so they have to turn and go back.
So they just basically waited them out.
So the joke is then the three planes are supposed to peel off to the right to go
to the drop where they're going to drop the drugs.
Two of them peel off,
the other one does it and they figure it out.
It's cause the guy fell asleep.
He had it on autopilot I guess.
So Tom Cruise is trying to fucking wake the guy up,
all right?
He can't wake him up.
So he comes up with his plane and he just ever so slightly just hits his,
his wing,
the guy sleeping wing with his wing.
Right.
There's no fucking way you can do that.
Correct.
Yeah.
You know,
I know I've seen these guys refuel and you know,
you kind of bumped into that thing,
but it's made out of like rubber.
Right?
I know I'm sounding like a fucking moron,
but I was looking at that goal and that's not possible weight.
Is it possible?
Is that a true story that the drug smuggler told?
I mean,
I've seen guys in fucking helicopters not check their surrounding areas,
make a turn and the main rotor blade fucking,
uh,
does a nice trim job is some trees.
And this is what always blows my mind.
These fucking assholes don't immediately set it down and checked if they did any
damage to the blade.
They just fucking pull power and they take off like they're the fucking,
like there were a landscape or with the most goddamn overhead ever.
Um,
yeah,
I was just like,
why didn't he just yell into the fucking headphones?
I,
you mean he did,
but I don't know.
Anyways,
so it's just a question I have.
Uh,
I know halfway through that I just in my head was like,
there's no fucking way you can do that though.
Why would you risk that?
Okay.
You know,
um,
gal at work had dream about me.
Oh,
here we go.
Jesus Christ.
We've got to red shoot diary here.
Now listen,
if you have a dream about a woman at work,
don't fucking tell you did I don't,
I don't think he could do that anymore.
I have fucking dream about you.
I was laying there,
Roy,
he came in and you had your girls out,
right?
All right.
Hey,
Billy dozer,
Bill Dozer.
I get,
hey bill dozer.
Okay.
I have a story you may find humorous slash.
Scary.
It concerns a lady I work with.
So I've been talking to this chick for a few days and I know she digs me lots of
touching,
closeness,
Yada,
Yada.
Bullshit.
I like her,
but now,
but I'm not,
I'm now concerned.
This morning she told me she had a dream about us dating for five years in
addition to this.
She claimed I failed to propose to her during those five years.
Oh yeah.
Do this.
This is a open and shut case.
Yeah.
Fucking God blessed this woman for being honest.
Dude.
I,
yeah.
Walk away slowly,
briskly and anything.
You can do anything you want because you're not in a relationship.
Just anyways,
he goes,
now am I wrong for thinking this was completely crazy?
It sounded sort of made up,
which made it 10 times worse.
Exactly.
Uh,
I like the girl,
but with this statement,
I kind of feel like she wants to keep me in a body bag or some shit.
Uh,
there's one fucking thing that I learned in my adult life.
It is go with your gut.
Go with your gut.
You know,
something I fucking,
like three weeks ago I was talking to this guy and who's on the road?
He's a tour manager for all the
other fucking people.
Right.
And he told me one of his clients was that this particular club and this
particular club,
I always had a feeling the club owner was stealing from me,
which is something about his vibe,
you know?
I just,
I just could feel it.
I was like,
this person that doesn't like me or they're fucking stealing from me.
I just was weird and a couple of weeks ago I was talking to the person in that
club owner's name came up.
He said,
yeah,
he goes,
I caught that guy putting another extra row of fucking chairs in there,
blah,
blah.
And I was like,
I fucking knew it.
I knew in my gut was literally saying and for the longest time I didn't listen
to it.
If your gut is saying this person wants to put you in a body bag or some shit,
yeah,
that's,
that's the feeling you're going to go into a relationship with.
Anyways.
I privately consulted some folks we work with about her dream.
Probably a bad idea.
Absolutely a bad idea.
If this is a spy movie,
like those people are now running for their lives after you get whacked because
they know that they also have the information anyways.
And they seem to think she simply an awkward girl.
They think I should give her a shot.
This sounds like you talked to women
because they're inserting,
because then what happens?
They insert themselves into the fucking situation and you know,
they,
that's just how it is now.
If you asked the fucking guy,
you know,
I dunno what we do.
We cock block is what the fuck are we doing?
Um,
it's funny.
Women in courage,
go ahead.
Co Co dater,
dater.
You know,
we fucking cock block.
It's bad.
Anyways,
what do you think bill?
Billy,
but plug,
am I too harsh or is she doing her best?
Freddy Kruger impression.
Thanks.
I,
you go with the gut dude.
You know what I mean?
That's going to be the YC your kids.
You're gonna have to say that to your kids one day.
What was it like when you first met your mother while she was I met,
met her mother.
Wow.
It was cool.
But,
uh,
then I got the vibe that,
she wanted to keep me in a body bag of some shit.
You guys want to get ice cream?
You know?
Fuck that dude.
Fuck that.
I would uh,
go with,
he got plenty of fish in the sea.
Walk away
dated for five years.
And you did,
you didn't propose to me.
She's already putting pressure on you.
Okay.
Um,
I don't know if somebody is putting pressure on her,
but she's putting pressure on herself,
but like that's her fucking problem.
That's not your,
but you want that.
You want that in your life.
Okay.
Um,
space flight.
Yeah.
I want to fly like Ego and outer space.
There's no fucking hair.
Look at my fucking face.
Hey Bill,
if you could download your consciousness into a computer slash robot in order to
travel into space,
would you,
what the fuck did,
I don't know what that means.
Download by consciousness into a computer slash robot in order to travel into
space.
Would you know I'm what?
How,
how could I do that?
Can you do that?
Now you can do that and they can't cure hair loss.
Do.
That's the biggest fucking scam ever.
Um,
I mean the point of moving your consciousness is to live longer and not have the
survival requirements we normally have like oxygen,
food.
Oh.
And having to take shits,
you might just need some electricity,
which seems easier to produce than oxygen
and food in a long ass space.
Right?
I don't know.
My girlfriend broke up with me like a month ago and I'm drunk.
Just spit balling here.
Wait a minute.
I got to see if this is like some shit they're working on right now.
Okay.
This is how dumb I am.
It's all behind the time I am a technology.
Like I'm actually seeing,
can you wait?
Can you download your consciousness into a fucking appear?
Um,
what do I look up here?
What fucking list am I going to get put on if I fucking look this up?
Downloading
consciousness,
mind uploading
what enough.
Okay.
And as a picture says cyborg whole brain
emulation or Wbe,
mind upload or brain upload,
sometimes called mind copying.
Our mind transfer is the hypothetical,
hypothetical,
futuristic process of scanning the mental state,
including long term memory and self of a particular brain substrate and copy it
to a computer.
Do you realize,
do you realize that you could,
um,
it first,
okay,
let's just say they could do that.
Like they could do that right now.
The dumbest thing to do is to,
is to be part of that first wave and do it.
Don't fucking do it cause you don't know what's going to happen.
And then also very quickly they're going to be like,
well,
are there some things that I could like maybe just delete some memories.
Like if you had some chick he could navigate over,
he could just delete that out of your brain,
you know,
or something really fucking humiliating happened to you that caused you to
become like introverted.
Maybe get rid of that.
Maybe he could become a better person.
Or is it the painful things that make us stronger?
Okay.
That make us who we are.
When we return,
we'll be bringing Dr. Joyce brothers in here.
Um,
I never installed those doctors like Dr. Joyce brothers.
It's like everyday she's on the Hollywood squares.
It's like when a,
what point were you a practicing medicine?
You know,
celebrity.
I want to,
you know,
that's the last thing I'm gonna look up here.
History of celebrity.
Can't fucking spell the word.
Celebrity psychologists,
who's the first one?
List of psychologists,
timelines of psychology,
history of psychology that should have Tom cruise on it.
Cause he knows,
he knows the whole history of psychology right through.
He called it.
He called that Guy Glib and years later you found out that glitch son of a bitch
had a fucking God damn problem.
Did he?
Uh,
the breadth of diversity of psychology can be seen by looking at some of the
plot the fuck.
Just give me the list.
BF,
Jean Piaget,
Sigmund Freud.
These people actually be the most boring looking people I've ever seen in my
life.
Albert Bandura,
Leon Festinger.
I always felt like doctor Phil look like a corrupt cop,
doesn't he?
Because he's got a fucking pistol in his shoe.
Then after he accidentally kills you,
he fucking puts it in your hand.
Erick Erickson,
it sounds like a fake name.
He's got the white hair like Albert Einstein,
the mustache.
That was like the smart look back in the day.
Um,
celebrity
therapists,
uh,
this is my last,
my last attempt to hear what the fuck was Dr. Joyce
brothers
television vice show pioneer.
She was a pioneer.
Oh,
she died 85.
Okay.
Yeah,
I feel like an asshole.
Why would,
I was really shitting on her.
I liked her,
you know,
summer vacation after you did you pay broody came home.
She was on a fucking game.
Oh,
she was on in the afternoon.
Joyce brothers passes away peacefully at her home in New York City on Monday.
Joyce brothers,
the mother of pop site.
Oh,
pop psychology.
That's what I want to look up pop.
That's what I kind of just means.
You don't even have to be good at it,
right?
You just have to be like,
it's like psychologist with personalities.
So she was the first one.
Okay.
Pop psychology personalities.
How can I get to what the Fuck I want here?
History of personality psychology.
I use the word personality.
Snellman to this 10 famous psychologists and they're fucking achievement.
Can Somebody fucking help me out here?
Can somebody teach me how to use the Internet?
Yeah,
they give up.
No,
I don't give up.
I'm just going to take a break for the rest of the day.
I think it will play with my Kiddo and I'm going to fucking Boston this week,
baby.
I got Springfield on Thursday.
I got to TD bank,
north fucking garden.
All right.
On Friday.
And then I'm fucking in Connecticut where I think we're the fucking Hartford
whalers used to play.
Uh,
this is ridiculous.
How did this happen?
How did somebody who flunked every and height,
everything in high school I got,
I got to get these gigs out of the fucking way before somebody figures it out.
Thank you to everybody.
Bought all these goddamn tickets.
Um,
I'm going to eat perfect it fucking workout and be the best,
most rested shape I can to give you a fucking money's worth because this is a
really humbling experience.
Like I said,
I don't know if we'll ever get to do it again.
So I'm going to get all of it and I will,
and I'll be a,
I want to post some videos of a,
I'm going to be fucking jam.
And with some friends of mine that I used to fucking play with way back in the
day when I was living outside of Boston,
when we at the fucking garden playing fucking Ac DC when we were in the forum,
it was so,
you know,
you get together,
Hey,
do you know this song?
Do you know that song?
The one that we all fucking came together on was a van Halen eight talking about
love.
I played that.
Okay.
The Alex van Hailu parts in the fucking La Forum.
And I got to tell you,
dude,
it was fucking the sickest fucking,
I can't even explain it.
You just sit in on the drum chair going,
this is where fucking John Bonham looked out.
This is nuts.
This is fucking nuts.
Uh,
this is where I saw John thing like a fucking year ago.
Crushing it on the drums.
We've got the fucking red acrylic,
Ludwig set.
Um,
unbelievable.
So anyways,
that's the podcast.
I will check in you on Thursday.
Go fuck yourselves.
Go Patch and a,
I'm calling her right now.
Take the Broncos with the points.
All right.
Now.
So the decision you need to make is,
okay.
Bill just said what he's going to do.
All right.
This is like crap.
So I bet on the past or the don't pass line.
All right.
It's up to you.
So don't fucking wine to me if you lose your money.
That's what I'm betting.
I'm betting the farm.
I'm taking the Broncos with the points.
I don't even know the spread.
I can't even name the Bronco's quarterback.
I just know they got fun.
Milla.
Um,
and I like that.
Okay.
All right.
Bye.